iceman yes
man of ice i'm sorry is something wrong
professor i'm just
trying to figure out what are your
powers again professor i
i i make ice oh i know it's laughable
how okay i'm just trying to figure out
what i can do with a man whose weakness
is room temperature okay right but
professor the ice that i make is cold
uh-oh look out they didn't bring layers
good thing ice man is here go inside get
an electric blanket in a hot water
bottle i'd i'd like to point out i've
been a very valuable part of this team
hey iceman what's your weakness
salt
that thing that's everywhere
kitchens restaurants that's your
kryptonite salt
kryptonite right marvel
do you understand that i spontaneously
if i'm ever on a lazy norland's porch
and it's really balmy and my iced tea
starts to get a little little tepid i'll
call you you're on speed dial as the
[ __ ] who can make my drink a little
better hey
i'm a hero right named ice man that's
really creative he makes ice call him
ice man
why not just call wolverine claws man or
cyclops laser beams shooting out of his
face man
did you name yourself
yeah good job
look ice man if i wanted a useless bald
guy standing around the fight not doing
anything i'd i'd hire seal at least he
could serenade the battle
i just think that
i've been a part of this team
i think there's a bigger picture here
than just me baby
to me
there was a nice way to do this
did you know that where it is
in
you're fired fire which would kill you
baby
okay it's gonna be in my head for about
a month but it was worth it